[Musique]
jamie profitant d'un beau gosse voilà
était sûr à star était suivi
beaubois très bonne valeur il est très
gentil mais en gros bisous l'enregistrer
la cei est afférente 508 avec le beau
gosse aquapole si je vous disais par
l'illusion de tous personne ne l'a fait
[Musique]
oui
ça
bonello discuter discute
m
départ
aucune fille plus belle que moi la plus
belle
[Musique]
plus belle que toi d
et voilà et voilà oh la la
voilà les nouveaux plata le dimanche
matin sous la coulée une grande
chanteuse
ce sont quoi un peu mieux je le sais oui
le des plaies et moi j'étais noir et la
soie oui mais c'est pas la même chose
et face aux et des brésiliens alors nous
sommes sous l'eau selon les minutes
romance avec chloé mortaud avait dû
présenter ta marque stella
[Musique]
soit yann enquêtes paranormales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]